la tradition ne se perd pas bien au
contraire en ce 1er mai ils étaient
nombreux à vouloir leur fleur porte
bonheur
pourtant dimanche pour avoir son brin de
muguet il fallait se lever tôt certains
ont eu de la chance je me suis dit je
vais atteindre dimanche parce que c'est
le premier mais j'y arrive pas en retard
j'ai eu du mal à en trouver oui et
d'autres moins moi sur lyon on en trouve
à des carrefours mais là chez
bizarrement j'ai pas vu d'habitude il ya
des petits jeunes
rien qu'en inde de l'argent n'est pas
trouvée j'aurais voulu enfin vraiment
des brins de muguet par des compositions
les fleuristes ont été pris d'assaut
comme ici à guyancourt où il ne restait
plus beaucoup de muguet en fin de
matinée les professionnels sont doutés
cette année avec la météo capricieuse du
mois d'avril
il a eu du mal à pousser les production
était réduite due au mauvais temps les
en serre et son épouse ont été très très
vert le millier de tête heurta vers les
fournisseurs nous ont appelés pour nous
dire que nos commandes intéressante
du coup
on n'avait plus le muguet à midi dans
les rues les vendeurs de muguet à eux
aussi se faisait rare mais avec de la
persévérance on pouvait quand même
espérer souhaitait du bonheur et de la
chance en ce 1er mai